Film Courage: Well Dan, we’ve pulled a few
comments left on some of our Film Courage
Youtube channel videos and we wanted to run
them by you to see what you think (because
they do have valid points).
One comments is: “Anyone who says there
is not a formulaic process in mainstream Hollywood
movies (and movies in general) is kidding
themselves.
We expect a certain story structure based
on a thousand years of Western storytelling.
Deviate at your own risk!”
Dan Calvisi: I would agree with that except
that it’s not a formula, it’s a form.
A formula would dictate what you write.
A form is dictating how you structure it,
at what point do you reveal things, at what
point should the story keep moving forward
and keep flowing rather than stop dead in
its tracks or just have an 8-page dialogue
scene?
So it’s not formula, it’s form.
And I constantly remind my clients about that
and my students.
It’s really important to understand that.
Film Courage: Interesting.
I like that.
Another comment “No wonder people are dissatisfied
with Hollywood.
Every movie is similar and so predictable
that the industry has committed the biggest
sin.
It is so predictable that it bores one to
tears.
The story plot lines really are business plans
in disguise instead of entertainment.”
Dan Calvisi: That can be true and I do see
that being true in more and more Hollywood
movies (the franchise films).
They are very formulaic and they are employing
the same character arcs, the same themes.
Like in animation, it’s the theme of ‘Believe
in yourself.
You can do anything.’
And I think it’s more interesting when you
see an animated film that is a little more
complex than that.
It’s a little more complicated than that.
So I do like to see other themes explored
and a little bit more intelligent exploration
of character and theme.
I do agree that a lot of the franchise films
are becoming similar because they are using
similar character arcs and similar themes
and similar plot devices.
A lot of the action movies today I am just
so bored by because it’s just battle after
battle even something like the movie LOGAN.
LOGAN was very different from a lot of other
superhero films and I think the audience responded
because of that.
There was more character, it was darker, it
was more mature but once he starts slashing
in those action scenes, I honestly get a little
bored.
I’ve seen Wolverine slash with his claws
in what, 7 or 8 movies by now (maybe more)?
So those long extended action scenes and battle
scenes and car chases for me don’t impress
me so much because I’ve seen them in so
many movies.
Now maybe for 12, 14, 15-year-olds, it is
more interesting and that is the core audience.
A screenwriter shouldn’t necessarily be
focused on that 14, 15-year-old boy audience
because they already have a bunch of highly-paid
writers in Hollywood who will write those
particular franchise films.
A screenwriter breaks in because they have
great characters, great dialogue and they
explore themes in interesting ways.
And they come up with a new and unique take
on a commercially proven genre.
That’s what you want to do.
You want to blow away the reader.
You want to write a great piece of material
so that you’ll get your foot in the door
and then they’ll hire you to do those assignments.
But they don’t necessarily want a new writer
to write a huge franchise film for no other
reason because those cost so much, they’re
not going to entrust a newbie with a 100 million
dollar movie.
And even if it’s a lower budget film, you
don’t have to write for the lowest common
denominator, you can write to the top of your
intelligence.
Film Courage: Don’t you have a book that
you’ve written about creating a super hero
script?
Dan Calvisi: I have a webinar that I’ve
written called ‘Writing the Super Hero Movie.’
And yes, I’m a huge fan of super hero films.
I like them when they really stand out with
some unique character development and interesting
themes.
I love most of the Marvel movies.
They are getting a little more formulaic in
my opinion.
But familiar in the themes and action scenes
now.
But I do love the super hero genre and I’m
always hoping that a writer will do something
new with it.